everyone this is Kevin from the test
website com2 they're going to be going
over the Italian game which starts out
with Pawnee for Pawnee five nine f3
knight c6 and then Bishop to c4 very
strong opening from white been around
for a long time not quite as popular as
maybe the right Lopez with Bishop here
to b5 but right away the bishop coming
here to c4 attacks this square here on
f7 which is a very weak Square for black
early on with the King being the only
piece that defends it and considering
this pawn right here on e5 usually this
pawn would block here on e6 kind of stop
that defense so all in all this is going
to be a very strong attack why it's
going to be able to put a lot of
pressure on the square a lot of
different variations that you get into
actually end up sacrificing this bishop
here on f7 so a very aggressive move
Black has a lot of different options
we're going to go over today how to kind
of approach different styles of play if
you want to be more aggressive or more
passive and then talk about some of the
traps that you may see from black and
make sure that you don't fall for those
traps because there are quite a few the
first variation we're going to look at
is Bishop here to c5 just
counter-attacking the exact same thing
that white is doing while both sides do
have a very central centralized Bishop
this is actually somewhat of a quiet
game you're not you're really going to
see things get too out of hand usually
you'll see the mainline continue with
Knight to c3 Knight to f6 potentially
pawn to d3 maybe pawn to d6 Castle on
the kingside for both sides of the board
the the central board is all kind of
clogged up you may see Knight here to d5
maybe sacrifice some material here in
the middle of the board but all in all
there's not going to be any crazy
fireworks that go off in this game again
it's going to be somewhat quiet now why
does have some options doesn't have to
go for more of the quiet game instead
could go for a slightly more aggressive
opening he could always try for the
Evans gambit which is pawn here to be
for giving up material and then playing
pawn here to see
three after the bishop moves back
there's really where doesn't matter
where it goes well let's say it comes
back here to a five then pushing forward
with pawn here to d4 trying to break up
the center of the board right here is
going to be a very very aggressive move
another move that you could see not
quite as often but the Jerome gambit and
that is after the bishop comes here to
just go ahead and take right away with
your bishop here on f7 after the King
takes here then I could take here on e5
after Knight recaptures then the queen
up here to h5 check getting ready to
capture material right here we do always
later have the move pushing forward pawn
here to d4 so this is an aggressive move
I don't see that often I don't recommend
it myself
it's very easy for black to hold on to
this since white doesn't have too much
material in the game now one pretty
aggressive move that white can play is
the Italian gambit that is pawn here to
d4 now depending on how black wants to
defend this if he decides he wants to
take with this pawn right here white can
always opt for playing pawn here to c3
and then after it takes here recapturing
with the knight here on C three and this
is a variation that you'll see quite
often for me I like to play it giving up
some extra material especially upon to
gain a big advantage as far as more
minor pieces material advantage in the
center of the board this also kind of
opens the game up a little bit and I
don't like to play kind of a closed
boring non aggressive game that's not my
style so playing that pawn to c3 and
then after they take retaking here with
our night here on c3 is something that I
like to do quite often the next
variation that we're going to look at is
Knight to f6 and there's there's a few
options that why it has here one you can
continue with kind of the quiet game
which is a lot of times when people play
the Italian game they don't want to get
into anything too crazy maybe they even
want to play for a draw this can be a
very draw game so they could just play
Knight here to c3 they could play your
your normal pawn here to d3 getting
ready to castle on the Kings side if you
want to
a little bit more aggressive you can
play one of my favorite aggressive
openings in chess and that is the fried
liver attack so you have the knight here
to g5 now your opponent can counter that
with the Traxler gambit so they have
that option as well so this is again
going to be a lot of fun to play and so
a lot of times I may play the Italian
game just so i can get some games under
my belt with the fried liver attack just
because it does a lot of fun to play so
you can kind of choose if you like to
play more of kind of a slow methodical
game waiting for move 15 to 17 to kind
of break open the sin of the board and
try something then you can play for a
little slower type of pawn to d3 you can
even castle if you wanted to night here
to c3 is more common move early on but
if you want to be more aggressive you
can always play for the fried liver
attack with the knight here to g5 the
next variation is Bishop here to e7 this
is probably the most passive way that
black can actually play this is a very
very draw game plays very similar to
kind of the old Indian defense if you're
familiar with that very sound defense
but not really even trying to do
anything you know usually that the
bishop here on g7 fee encountering the
bishop on the King side is going to be a
little bit more aggressive Bishop here
to e7 is not trying to do that all one
thing white definitely needs to make
sure that they do if they come to this
position is to be very aggressive they
need to try to gain as much control the
center of the board that they can so
pushing forward with pawn here to d4 is
very very good now let's say they decide
to go ahead and take here on d4 one
thing I again like to always do is play
pawn here to c3 again if they capture
we're going to recapture with our
Knights
that's just increasing our development
in the center of the board we have a
huge presence with our minor pieces
controlling this and the board that's
going to be good even if they don't take
here you could see if they want to
continue to play passive pawn here to d6
that's fine you can now just completely
open the game up pawn taking here on e5
if they recapture here you could come up
here take with your queen they're
probably take with their Bishop to make
sure they can still castle
on one side aboard but this is a lot
more open than you know someone playing
this bishop here to e7 this is a little
more crazier than they even want to do
and so you can play knight here to c3
get your bishop involved castle on the
Queen side get a very very strong attack
here but this allows you some options
even if your opponent wants to play
pretty passive similar to the bishop
here to e7 another very passive move
they could play is pawn to d6 and you're
going to be doing the same thing you're
going to be playing pawn here to d4
trying to be as aggressive as possible
this is really just a purely defensive
move so you kind of do hope that they
take this material right here you can
kind of side it if you want to continue
with your normal knight here to d4 and
if they recapture you can capture with
your queen you can always go for after
they take here pawn to c3 and if they
take you can recapture here on c3 so you
have that option always keep that in the
back pocket when you're playing this
type of opening just because I like to
play it quite often and even if they
don't take you you still are going to
have a pretty good game you know if they
play you know the bishop coming out here
to g4 common move you can just take this
pawn here on d4 you're playing this pawn
here on c3 because you expect them to
take it you can recapture but if they
don't more times than not you can just
come up here and take this pawn on d4
and things are going to be really really
good for you now if you were to play me
and you were playing the town game and I
was the black pieces I would pretty much
always play the ruzo gambit its pawn
here to f5 plays very similar to the
King's gambit which is my favorite
opening from white but it gives me a lot
of different options and a lot of times
my opponent will take here on f5 if
you're not completely familiar with this
opening for white my recommendation is
that you don't take it you can just get
into a lot of problems after pawn here
to e4 forcing the knight to move
bringing up the pawn here to d5 forcing
this bishop to move all of a sudden
you're getting all your pieces involved
into the game the knight here to f6 it
can be very very difficult for white to
hold on to this if they're not very very
familiar so you can study up if you want
to my recommendation is if you ever see
pawn to f5 more than likely your
opponent is studied up on it and there
they know how to play the ruse Oh gambit
which is very dangerous just play pawn
here to d3 this kind of gives them a
weird awkward setup especially on the
King side you have a nice central set up
with your knight here your Bishop here
and c4 still hunting down on this f7
square so you can be pretty passive if
you want to play a little bit more
aggressive you can always play pawn here
to d4 counter attacking the center of
the board but my recommendation is pawn
here to d3 castle on the Kings side play
knight here to see through you're going
to have a great setup there's nothing
really that black is going to be able to
throw at you that's going to make you
fall into a bad board state you're
definitely going to be ahead in this
board state the last line that you may
see from black is Knight to d4 this is
the Blackburn shilling gambit again one
of those things where if you're not too
familiar with this opening from white
then I recommend not taking the gambit
here on e5 because that's kind of what
they want you to do here then their play
is Queen to g5 attacking both this
Knights here and the pawn here on g2
white could always take be pretty crazy
with Bishop taking here on f7 and then
the King to d8 now White's still going
to go down in material he's either gonna
lose this knight or he's going to lose
you know this pawn and potentially some
other material whether it's here on e4
or even some other pawns over here so I
wouldn't even get involved into this if
you see this unless you're super
familiar with the blackburn shilling
gamete instead I would just take this
night here on d4 force them to recapture
here and then you have options you can
always play castle on the King side you
could play my favorite which we've
already talked about before is the pawn
here to c3 seeing if they want to take
and you recapture with your night here
on c3 if they allow you to do this
you're almost never going to lose you
have all the material in the center of
the board your next moves usually going
to be pawn here to d4 they have really
nothing going on they've given up their
central pawn right here you have both
your central pawns they've given up
their knight which really kind of
counter-attack
the center of the board so you're doing
a great job right now and you haven't
even given up material on board which a
lot of times you'll do with that pawn
here to c3 just to gain that extra tempo
with your knight here so again if you
see the blackburn shilling i say just go
ahead and take the knight instead of
trying to take that material then here
on e5 so a lot of different variations
you can go into the italian game you can
decide if you want to be more aggressive
or more passive some of the variations
that we talked about whether these are
the the Evans gambit or the fried liver
attack or the Traxler gambit or even the
Blackburn Schilling gambit these are all
other videos I've created so you can
definitely watch those if you want some
more in-depth analysis on some of the
lines but Italian game definitely try it
out especially if you like to play pawn
here to e4 which I like to do it kind of
give you a change of pace from your
normal ride Lopez bring your Bishop here
to b5 or for me the King's gambit with
pawn here to f4 so hopefully you guys
enjoy this video hopefully you learned
something hopefully you can avoid some
of the traps in the Italian game and
I'll see you guys the next video thanks
for watching